me da gusto que estén de regreso pues en
el vídeo pasado yo les había mostrado
que si nosotros tenemos una casa en
renta y una casa en venta y las dos son
casas iguales y bueno los precios de
rentar y de comprar alquilar son números
eso depende del mercado que haya en tu
localidad pero sin entrar en por mayores
yo te había demostrado que cuando tú
comprabas una casa estaba quemando 40
mil pesos de tu dinero mientras que
cuando renta va solamente quemadas 26
mil pesos de tu dinero y bueno esto sin
entrar en por mayores sin contar por
ejemplo qué es lo que pasa con otros
impuestos o con otros precios pero al
final esta cantidad de dinero es la
cantidad de dinero que tú vas a perder
de tu bolso no es una cantidad de dinero
que vaya a ir a tu capital o una
cantidad de dinero que vaya a aumentar
el precio de la casa es la cantidad de
dinero que es simple y sencillamente se
va a quemar es un dinero que tú nunca
vas a volver a ver y es que al final
cuando tú piensa un préstamo para
comprar una casa entonces estás rentando
una cierta cantidad de dinero el interés
es una renta y es que al final cuando tú
tienes un activo no se ese activo que
sea tu dinero o inclusive una casa
pero tú debes una ciudad de cantidad de
dinero por tener ese cierto activo
entonces el interés es la renta de tu
pago mensual al final es tu elección si
quieres ser un inquilino de una deuda o
un inquilino de una casa pero lo que sí
te demostré es que si eres un deudor o
un rentador o un inquilino de dinero vas
a perder casi el doble de dinero que es
lo que pérdidas rentando la casa bueno
eso sí uno de los argumentos negativos
que tú podrías utilizar a tu favor es
que me subiera en la renta supongamos
que me subes la renta en el siguiente
año o después de unos cientos años a
tres mil quinientos cuánto es 3.5 por 12
bueno 3 puntos 5 por 2 42 y si a esto le
sumamos los 10 mil pesos que yo tenía de
interés por mis 250 mil pesos es más 10
no no nos pueden más bienes menos 10
entonces sería menos 20 son 32 mil pesos
al final tienes razón las rentas suben
después de un cierto tiempo pero aunque
me subí a la renta 500 pesos yo sigo
pagando 32 mil pesos a comparación de
los 42 mil casi 42 mil pesos que tú
pagas al comprar una casa
y es más hasta podemos calcular la
cantidad de dinero que nosotros
tendremos que pagar de renta para perder
41 mil 500 pesos de nuestro bolsillo
entonces tenemos 41 mil 500 pesos más 10
mil pesos que nos da el banco son 51 mil
500 pesos por lo tanto vamos a poner los
51 mil 500 pesos dividido entre 12 meses
51 mil 500 dividido entre 12 meses me va
a dar la cantidad de dinero que me
tendrían que cobrar de renta para que
las cuentas fueran iguales y son 4 mil
300 pesos entonces vamos a escribirlo 4
mil 300 pesos para que las cuentas sean
iguales es decir que la cantidad de
dinero que perdemos rentando una casa
sea igual a la cantidad de dinero que
perdemos cuando compramos una casa otro
punto en el favor es que cuando tú te
quieras cambiar de casa o necesites
cambiarte de esa casa entonces vas a ir
a rentar una nueva casa y vas a poner
esta casa en renta en cuánto tiempo tú
vas a necesitar alquilar esta casa para
que tú no salgas perdiendo nada en
ningún mes y bueno hay que tener cuidado
porque otros argumentos demoníacos que
te podrían dar es decirte que tu casa se
va a apreciar o va a aumentar de valor
cada
lo que pase sin embargo esto no es
cierto y se nota actualmente en eeuu las
casas se están bajando de valor pero
bueno vamos a suponer que sí es cierto
que las casas van a aumentar de valor
cuánto se tendré que apreciar esta casa
para que las cuentas fueran iguales
entonces cuántos 41 mil 500 si a esto le
quitamos lo que perdíamos en la otra
casa que eran 26 mil pesos entonces me
salen 15 mil 500 pesos 15 mil 500 pesos
es más favorable el caso de rentar al
caso de comprar una casa
ahora bien vamos a suponer que lo que
queremos es que esta casa se aprecie
esta cantidad de dinero para que me sea
más favorable comprar una casa entonces
voy a hacer 15 mil 500 y a esto lo voy a
dividir entre lo que vale mi casa que si
lo ponemos en punto decimal van a ser
1000 y esto me va a salir 0.01 55 estoy
sacando el porcentaje por lo tanto es
1.5 por ciento lo que se tiene que
apreciar mi casa para que mis cuentas
salgan iguales es decir para que yo
obtengan los 15 mil 500 pesos de mi
diferencia entre los 41 mil 500 pesos
que yo tengo al comprar una casa a
comparación de los 26 mil pesos que yo
tengo al rentar una casa es decir
solamente quería ver la diferencia entre
estas dos y bueno que una casa se
aprecie en 1.5 por ciento es muy poco
realmente en el 2004-2005 de 2006 y
hasta el 2007 las casas se apreciaban
aumentaban su valor en un 10 hasta un 15
por ciento del valor de la casa y era
algo sorprendente era muy bueno que tu
casa aumentara de valor sin hacer nada
solamente estar sentado un año en esa
casa
un 10 por ciento un 15 por ciento o hay
veces que hasta más sin embargo alguna
vez hice unos vídeos sobre la hoja de
balance y en esos vídeos veíamos lo que
pasaba con tu casa en lugar de aumentar
de valor disminuya de valor es decir
tengas un menos 1.5 por ciento y en ese
caso no solamente serías pagando los 41
mil 500 pesos que tu dinero se va a la
basura sino que además vas a pagar 15
mil 500 pesos de tu dinero que se va a
ir a la basura y bueno yo entiendo que
esa necesidad irracional de comprar una
casa esté justificada cuando la casa
a aumentar de precio es decir cuando la
casa va a apreciarse cada vez más y se
aumenta en un 10% en un 12% 15% pues
suena bastante bien pero hay que tener
cuidado porque si tú tienes un
departamento o dios no lo quiera tienes
una casa y está empieza a devaluarse es
decir a perder el precio entonces la
situación se pone realmente muy fea y
esto está sucediendo en la actualidad en
lugares en eeuu como florida o
california o el área de la bahía de san
francisco
ponen es bueno es que mi casa va a
aumentar su valor en un 1 por ciento 2
por ciento mínimo y esto va a ser la
diferencia pero yo les pregunto por qué
tu casa aumentará su valor en ese 1% o
en ese 2% es decir necesitamos una razón
lógica para que alguna persona quiera
pagar un 2% más por esa casa es porque
la renta aumentará en un 2% al año pues
actualmente en el área de la bahía del
2001 al 2003 las rentas han disminuido
pues la gente fue despedida a otros
tantos se mudaron de casas y esto hizo
que las rentas bajarán de precio ya
pesar de que las rentas bajarán de
precio el precio de las casas fueron
aumentando hasta que alguien se dio
cuenta que no había una razón económica
lógica para que las casas seguían
aumentando el precio mientras la renta
seguían disminuyendo de hecho lo que
quiero ver en el siguiente vídeo es
analizar por qué aumenta de precio una
casa y la única razón por la que una
casa aumente de precio es porque haya
una mayor facilidad para comprar casas y
para eso los bancos tienen que dar
mayores facilidades para que se pueda
obtener un préstamo es decir pedir menos
que se consigue un préstamo y de hecho
se pasaba hay personas a las cuales
ganaban 40 mil o 30 mil pesos al año y
les llegaban a apresar hasta un millón
de pesos para comprar su casa y me llama
mucho la atención porque solamente
tenían que decir lo que ganaban no
tienen que demostrarlo y bueno ya con el
dinero que les prestaba el banco
entonces decidían ir a comprar su casa y
la gente como veía que estaban comprando
muchas casas entonces decidían aumentar
el valor de su casa y por lo tanto las
casas valían cada vez más pero fue
entonces cuando se cumplió la profecía
premeditada porque si las casas se
empiezan a bajar de precio entonces al
hacer el comparativo de la ecuación de
renta contra la compra de casa es decir
de este dinero a comparación de este
dinero entonces sale perdiendo el que
compra una casa y de hecho si tú eres la
persona que quiere que quiere comprar
esta casa se cree será un poco triste y
es un poco melancólico esto pero si tú
eres la persona que quiere comprar una
casa y por algún motivo pierdes tu
trabajo o lo que sea y ya no puedes
pagarle al banco entonces el banco se va
a cobrar con toda tu casa entera es
decir también vas a perder tus 250 mil
pesos que tendrías de capital aunque
bueno también
de verlo es que tú vendieras esa casa
pero si a ti te urge el dinero entonces
la casa no la vas a vender al precio que
todas compras te vas a tener que vender
en un precio un poco más chico ahora
bien otra cosa por la cual yo no
compraría actualmente una casa es porque
te limita a tus opciones de trabajo es
decir si tú pierdes tu trabajo en el
lugar en donde compraste tu casa y
encuentras otro trabajo en otro lugar en
otro sitio entonces tú vas a tener que
ir y mudarte al otro sitio y por lo
tanto vas a tener que vender esta casa y
perder tiempo y dinero o en otra
situación lo que va a hacer es quedarte
con tu casa y limitarte los trabajos que
hay en tu ciudad y si tú eres una
persona que renta en cualquier momento
tú puedes agarrar tus cosas e irte a
vivir a otra parte pero bueno al final
éste es un vídeo áspero de rentar contra
comprar una casa espero que te haya
servido y te haya quitado de dudas por
lo tanto nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo